but there is a big protest coming um
as it is just about a week it is in dc
what is the protest called like the
march against mandates is it are you
sure it's called march against
manchester no but that's what i think it
is yeah i don't think that's the point
so we have this story from newsweek
joe rogan and robert kennedy jr to speak
at conspiracy theorist vaccine mandate
protest
wow what a story newsweek you and palmer
or how do you pronounce your name i
wonder where you got that information i
reached out to joe rogan for comment and
i said are you going to this thing he
said no that was it i'm like why are
they reporting he's going to this um but
i suppose it's easier for me to ask him
because i know him than it was for this
journalist but where the hell did they
get this information to claim he was
going to be there i had to wonder
because when i saw this i was like if i
tell people joe's not going to be there
less people will show up right because
if they genuinely thought joe would be
there i mean you might fill a stadium
with people showing up
is it possible this guy was like i'm
just going to say it because then
everyone's going to want to be there
we saw it occupy wall street they
claimed radiohead was coming and
thousands like ten thousand how many
people were there luke like ten thousand
it was it was ridiculous huge coming yep
but everyone was there right before they
were about to allegedly sweep the park
and kick everyone out they say he is
listed as being among the speakers at
the march which ends the lincoln
memorial
so
where where does that come from um
probably some fake news probably either
someone trying to make sure that more
people show up to this protest i mean
we're talking about this protest now
um i think it's a worthwhile protest i
don't know who sent them the information
obviously brett weinstein is also
weinstein is also making sure that
people understand that this is kind of
fake news being spread out there uh but
there's going to be a lot of important
people out there i think it's an
important protest i think it's an
important discussion that needs to be
had in this country um
as far as this fake news i don't really
have anything else to say other than
that i'm sure i'm sure
both people that want people to show up
and people that want to demonize this
thing are going to be um spreading a lot
of information um i for one would love
to see
americans stand up and rise up and i've
been i've been disappointed that we
haven't seen the same sort of massive
marches we're all on twitter and we're
watching these marches all across europe
um in australia everywhere
and there's been less of it in the
united states and i think we're due
for a nice grassroots uprising but i
would i would again say i'm going to
beat this dead horse it's got to be
peaceful
because everybody's watching and one bad
actor will will destroy your message and
and transform what what could be
a pivotal moment in american history and
the feds are dying for an incident to
happen that will turn violent that will
hurt other people that will work in
their benefits so they desperately want
something like that
want something like that to happen i
would even say as desperate as to even
potentially manufacture it that's my
purpose so it is it is defeat the
mandates dc
and they say
after they get the lincoln memorial
recording artists prominent doctors
journalists pro athletes actors and
premier thought leaders will give a
series of inspiring talks and musical
performances i don't see if it says who
is going to be there though or why they
were claiming that it was going to be
jumped in it opened it looks like the
the flccc has also provided a lot of
important information to a lot of people
that
even information that i personally use
myself
and they do a lot of good work so it's
cool to see them involved here uh chris
martinson of peak prosperity he's also
going to be there he's going to be
speaking and participating he's uh you
know he's been on the show he's a friend
of mine as well dr malone dr mccullough
um and i'm not sure about robert kennedy
jr i don't know if he's confirmed does
conspiracy mean anything anymore it
doesn't mean anything does it the media
is just like a conspiracy march and i'm
like that doesn't mean anything i
literally don't care what you think you
are all crackpots you believe the
covington kid bs imagine taking medical
advice from people who believe jesse
smellet sorry the moment you said that
i'm just like bro i don't care what you
have to say about conspiracy theories at
all literally the the spoiler alert uh
yeah march would be a more appropriate
name for what's been happening here um
and again the corporate media is going
to vilify it because it goes against a
lot of their corporate media partners
and uh this is bad for business for the
big industries that are tied to them so
obviously they're going to try to attack
it in any way that they can it's only a
matter of time before we get that email
where it's like hi i'm with pfizer and
we'd love to sponsor your show
and then all of a sudden one day we're
like you know what we're totally in
favor of this people should get 12.
12 vaccines talk to your doctor about
your 12th vaccine today oh my gosh no no
we won't we won't play those games be
interesting to do a pfizer ad and then
at the end after the ad be like yeah
pfizer's trash this authoritarian
corporation like i wonder if that'd be
that'd be good that'd be fun if i ever
received anything where it was like we'd
like to sponsor your show i'd probably
just publish all the documents and i'm
saying that now so it'll definitely
never happen but i would thoroughly
enjoy being like thank you for the
request here's here twitter here's what
they're sending people i would love to
see uh tim pool brought to you by pfizer
all of a sudden i'm wearing a suit yeah
we're in a different room visor beanie
we're in an office building we're all
wearing uh you know
black tie suits
luke's pronouncing everything
pronouncing everything correctly it's
just
it's bizarro pfizer world right yeah
well i'll say this uh
luke you're going to be at the protest
yes
i got to tell everybody be careful
because agent provocateurs man
absolutely that's why it's important to
live stream i'm going to be probably
live streaming if i could get good cell
phone signal and videotaping everything
making sure that of course we get
everything on the record because the
only thing really preventing and
stopping something is being fully
transparent open uh and honest about
everything and the best way to do that
is to live stream so i'm gonna be live
streaming on youtube.com we are i'll
just say if i was there at a protest and
i saw someone something like this trying
to act before get violent i would stop
them
i would and and we saw that there was a
lot of this some of this went on these
really cool videos there was a guy who
was ripping bricks off out of the
sidewalk oh yeah and then activists left
reactivists grabbed him and dragged him
to the police and they were like get him
out of here we do not want this and then
the cops even let one of the guys go
like he got caught up in and they're
like okay you're cool and they arrested
the guy who was vandalizing stuff that's
what you need to see
now i don't know what people should do
for legal reasons i have no idea so talk
to the organizers but don't let people
do any of that crazy stuff because you
will get some antifa type who's going to
show up wearing a maga hat and be like
i'm going to make them all look crazy
that's the problem is someone could go
there put on a manga hat and throw a
brick and then
that gives the government authority to
like send in troops
one guy can do that's crazy so we did we
dealt with this and this is before
smartphones were such a thing but i was
a tea party organizer and we organized
that massive march
in 2009 on the mall
and and you know no arrests no violence
um a couple kids got lost we found them
again it was like this beautiful
uh bottom-up thing but eventually
people that wanted to
sort of smear a reputation showed up and
and one of the tactics we used which i
believe we borrowed from the left was we
created signs that said this guy's not
with us
and we would surround a bad actor and we
don't know if the guy's a bad actor from
our side or their side
but if the behavior's wrong
if they were if they were doing
something violent or something racist we
would just surround them and they would
just leave
because they were outed
and it's it's hard to police a
grassroots movement and the way that mlk
did it with his march on washington it
was very carefully scripted the signs
were created by the organizers that's
not how it works anymore so you've got
to figure out some way
to police your own community you have
zero tolerance for bad behavior no
matter who's doing it
what do you guys think is gonna happen
peaceful massive how many people you
think some people are estimating a
hundred thousand but i think those are
uh over inflated numbers and you usually
you usually see numbers over-inflated
but at the same time we haven't seen a
protest here in the united states for a
very long time uh compare that to what's
been happening in france in austria in
australia in germany in the united
kingdom there have been massive protests
with tens of thousands of people some
instances even hundreds of thousands of
people coming to the streets saying
enough is enough and i think just being
able to see that kind of larger
representation does have some kind of
larger political change and does
put into people's minds that they're not
alone and i think that's that's
important and i think peaceful peaceful
rallying and peaceful protests are
extremely important and um you know who
knows what's going to happen but
um i'm going to be there to see it's
winter we got a snowstorm coming this
weekend
i'm not
i don't want to be debbie downer but i'm
not confident i was just go like in my
brain i was like i was going just going
to call you a debbie downer uh we were
supposed to go hiking for like so long
and tim's like now it's going to rain
that's raining no we're going now it's
not raining now we're supposed to go
hiking this weekend and tim's like oh
it's gonna snow we're not going i'm like
fake news we're gonna go anyway no it's
not it's true news it's absolutely true
news let me tell you let me tell you the
facts the first was actually raining it
was literally raining outside and luke
said who cares let's go anyway and i
said bro
it says it's going to keep raining until
i'm like pm yes
i don't think it's it's good to drive
two hours
and then just be like well it was
raining and we knew it was raining and
then waste the day driving two hours
back as it turns out the rain stopped
where where luke ended up going hiking
and he was fine
the only thing that really happened was
i wasn't willing to take the risk and
luke was and it benefited luke that's
the true news stop being fake news i
keep telling you the the the the weather
reports keep lying to you man just like
the media does
and then even if it is raining it'll
still be an interesting hike to go on we
just bring weather gear and still enjoy
the hike rather than just here's the
false framing from luke while we were
going to go hiking this weekend there is
a report that a major winter storm is
coming so what we said was how about we
go snowboarding or skiing instead so we
still go up to the mountain we still get
the views and luke said no no when then
he had none now that's fake news that's
fake news on your part i never said no
on that part you want to you want to go
like next weekend and well yeah because
uh it's it's a couple hour drive through
the snow we have to stay the night but
luke you work sundays and then you know
just but that's that's that's the truth
it's like you know luke trying to smear
me and
trying to pull a pull a daily beast over
here you got me thinking though that if
someone does decide to co-opt the
weather system and want to give us the
fake news that's a good way because
people trust that implicitly i've never
heard anyone question the weather even
when uh
just this past weekend they said it was
gonna rain and then it didn't rain i'm
telling you leave it there's no reason
to believe the news tim somebody there
was actually a meteorologist who pointed
this out he said when they were
predicting this big winter storm he was
like the the weather the weather system
is in the in the pacific ocean there's
no way you can accurately predict what
it's going to do in the next two weeks
so
i guess uh
it is still for the most part coming
true in a lot of ways it's not the same
as the projection from two weeks ago
obviously but we're supposed to get hit
with a big winter storm we're supposed
to get very very heavy snowfall out here
so
you know that that is bad news for us
because fortunately it's happening over
the weekend but it usually means that
it's harder to get out here so we'll
have to figure that stuff out you know
drive safely everyone yeah yep yep in
the middle of nowhere and the power
could go out yikes who knows thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time